if I was trying to you know get people
into the lab I would I mean I think
first and foremost the work that we do
is just really fun and engaging and I
love what I do like I said I before that
I get to apply math mathematics and sort
of problem-solving in mathematics to
understanding you know to make
observations of the natural world to
understand the natural world and how you
know we're connected to nature how we
adapt to our environment how pathogens
and humans have this arms race that we
are exploring so to me that's really fun
is that you know especially working in
infectious disease it's very interesting
because these passes these infectious
diseases these agents they evolve over
time so it's you know it's very much an
arms race and understanding how each
changes to protect itself and to
continue and so it's very much this
puzzle solving but with this great you
know urgency and importance in what you
find and the kinds of discoveries we
make have great implications to human
health and so for me I you know enjoy
very much there's the day to day
application so in order to do the work
that I do in Lassa fever
as I said before that that's an area
that's there's it's been so neglected in
a way it's actually because I think
enough West Africans are are immune to
it because probably natural selection
that it kind of it actually almost
clouds over how deadly this disease is
and that if it actually spread how how
actually catastrophic it could be and so
that's that's a disease that's been very
very well neglected so there aren't
really good Diagnostics there's only one
treatment ribavirin and it's not known
exactly its efficacy right now and so a
lot of what we need to do is build
infrastructure just to study that so on
a day to day basis the work that I do
also involves infrastructure building in
Africa and infrastructure building in in
this in the States towards application
in Africa so we're building diagnostics
based on recombinant DNA in order to
test people very quickly to see whether
or not they've been exposed to the
disease and so on a day to day basis
so it's nice about the work that we do
is that in order to do research we
actually have to build capacity and that
capacity has direct implications we also
have to do a lot of training of African
scientists and it's tremendous I mean
African scientists and doctors are some
of the most hard-working people that
I've ever met you know they wake up in
the morning they work into the night you
know they're very very focused are very
very committed because they see the day
to day implications of the diseases and
so right now we're working with the
University of Ibadan in Nigeria with
Christian happi and it's amazing I mean
so for me it's just wonderful to see him
and the commitment he's had to building
the site and training a lot of the
doctors of this hospital called hourua
in Inner Rua
that has many many patients of Lhasa and
so direct implications there but then
once we actually are able to investigate
the disease we can understand the virus
and how its what might be the pathogenic
traits of the virus and there might be
causing disease if there's different
variants in the virus community some
that are more deadly than others
understanding what it is that causes
that kind of you know virility and
strong outcome we can understand those
individuals that have immunity how
they've maintained immunity and and
hopefully use that towards understanding
the disease and the pathogenesis of the
disease and then maybe with therapeutic
implications so what's great about this
kind of work is that at every step you
get this grant you know gratification
about training scientists throughout the
world building Diagnostics that could
help on a day to day basis and then
doing the kind of research that will of
to understand this diseases
I always really liked math so math was
always the thing that I liked the very
most about mm-hmm better than anything I
like solving puzzles and I think
probably societally I like science I
like people and so I kind of began to
think I should be a doctor but it was I
don't know if that was necessarily like
just I enjoy I like biology a lot and I
definitely loved medicine but I think
the one thing that was always true is
that I always loved math a lot I just
adored the puzzles it was I just yeah
I've always liked problem-solving and so
I'm never I'm not really much like I
wasn't much into geometry or a lot of
the sort of spatial calculus or anything
like that I just really liked number
crunching in different ways I like I
love calculus I love linear algebra
probability and statistics that kind of
stuff I just really like that well there
I mean I had I had a long list of really
great math teachers too many to name and
not I think all along I had great like
math instruction actually probably my
best teacher the one that got me excited
about it from the earliest age was my
sister who used to teach me and she was
two years ahead of me sis used to teach
me what she learned in school in the
summers before so like I'd learned it
like a year and a half ahead in advance
and and she probably was the earliest
person that got me really excited about
math so she always taught me like
addition subtraction multiplication and
algebra like two years before schools
were teaching it and I think that got me
really excited about it so when I would
go into school it was weird because I
already knew everything that I was being
taught that year so I just got really
obsessive about it like I'd have to do
my multiplication to like multiplication
tables like faster than any but you know
I mean like to half time that kind of
stuff so I got really into because I was
learning it so early that I just got
really into like excellence in it of
yeah just doing the same stuff everyone
was doing but just doing it faster and
better like really enjoying that and so
that was probably like the spark that I
got really excited about that kind of
thing and then
I mean yet lots of teachers so I would
say that if there was a teacher that
kind of really inspired me it was mr.
bluish my biology teacher and ap biology
teacher in high school he got me really
excited about biology and mrs. people's
I took an anatomy and physiology course
and those courses in my high school were
incredibly good and so when I left by my
senior year I just really thought I was
going to be a biologist and genetics I
was really excited about so I think
that's so that's what I went into I had
to do it again I would have been a math
major probably a double major it did
take a lot of math classes but I would
taken a lot more